men from your experience do you think
men are more or women are abused more
just from personal experience not social
media not like just from people you know
personally that you would believe and
trust in my opinion um I think it's 50
50 do you know what I'm saying I can't
just say yeah a woman is more okay any
ladies there's a lot of men out there
don't say nothing so I say 50 50 you
know what I'm saying uh I would say well
let's put it this way I know about three
or four men who've been you know
supposedly been some one or two of them
was really really bad and I've known a
couple of I've known like one of the
girls I saw seeing like six months ago
was really badly abused like was
anorexic because of it XYZ
um personally I I view it more as like a
character like you have to be a certain
kind of person it's always it's always
people who just like have have
like they get into relationships too
young they build their personality by
being co-dependent on someone else it's
always those kind of the guys who get
abused are very like low-key emotional
dudes because they'll be telling us to
be like bro you're like six two bro like
what are you like why can't like you
know and he's like no I've got some deep
feeling so it's a certain kind of person
in my experience I haven't thought about
it in terms of like gender I think don't
you think it's like
oh I'm sorry
is there mandam it doesn't mean they
they don't go into a relationship and
they fall in love and you know all this
happens but I think
it's so hard to say who's who's more
because the men don't speak up like
we're like we're speaking here that's
the name part as well you know they made
them speak up because they don't want
that sometimes they're even afraid to
say okay babe I love you bye they're
afraid to say I love you but to their
girlfriends so imagine speaking about oh
she she hits me at home she scratches my
face she tears up my clothes you know
something but do you know what it is I
know something right it all depends
because
f a man
slapped a woman straight away that's
abuse
right but how many women out there and
they're slapping the men regularly but
nobody's seen it as abuse but if it was
the other way around because I'm sure
that somewhere everybody knows someone
who like I almost say oh you know I
snapped him in his face he was swollen I
snapped him in his face oh I waxed him
around the head or it's always something
just like it's nothing when it comes to
men but if but only because maybe
because she's a woman and it's weak so
the way it sounds like oh I just slapped
him but if it was a man now saying oh I
just slapped her because he's a man and
everyone's thinking about the force
behind it and I and I believe that when
it comes to abuse there's more men out
there being abused but because they
might say oh it's a slap or she's on her
period oh you know I mean oh she's got
trauma they don't they don't ever report
it because they just seen it as a slap I
think ever ever a man this gives a woman
a slap now
because of the slap on the sides of his
hand I don't know because of the
strength everybody's going to see as
some major abuse I think I think men
don't my honest opinions I think from my
experience people have seen in this
situation men don't report it because
and you can hate me if you want for
saying this they know it's weaken it
like like you you fully know that this
is pathetic in it like you're literally
getting abused by some by some five foot
two Latino thing and you you caught
feelings you caught feeling so deep that
you can't leave and now you're really
hurt and then six months you're gonna be
pushing the edgy Facebook post about you
know love and whatever listen they know
it's weak and that's why they don't
really come up people just which is why
I say I think it's a character thing the
dollies I know who have this experience
they're always like the wettest like
it's like you can see it I've had guys
say to me like um oh you know I'm in an
abusive relationship but I can't leave I
just like I can't override my emotions
my dad's the same you know sometimes
with the women in our families and our
genes like they just push it too far but
you know the man in our family just like
we just can't leave we just fall really
deeply in love and XYZ I looked at him I
felt really sorry for him because he was
he was a good looking guy who's from
like Yorkshire somewhere like that some
Village and you know I kind of got it
but it's a character in it and these
there are people who haven't learned
emotional resilience the people who
haven't learned Independence and they
just they just give up any any kind of
semblance of self-respect you know and
and decide that I'm not even gonna fight
that but I'll just follow my feelings
let me see me is everywhere around it's
not the it's not weak men
is a strong man
that the women are like you know I want
to slap in the men like you know what if
I if I slap her back I'm Gonna Knock her
the hell out so I'm just gonna walk away
from you you know what I mean and I
don't see any to me it's never it's
never been a a weak man it's always been
a strong a strong man and that's got
slapped but if the woman's having an
argue and the Mango's like I'm not a man
to look at the woman and say you know
what it depends on what happens if I if
I slap you back now
I'm gonna put myself in prison and I'm
gonna put you in hospitals you know what
I'm going to do I'm gonna go for a walk
and I know men that do that I also know
a man who the woman slapped him
so he bit slapped her back and he spent
the night in the police station
it depends on what you mean by strong
I've noticed it's mostly that the kind
of woman who do that tend to Target a
certain kind of guy like they can they
can tell who the wet guy is gonna catch
feelings hard is going to be in it
because there's some Amanda I'm like it
never happens to people like me it's not
even close because it's not even like
something like even possible but there's
it's the side that's why I said the guys
who deal with this they always and they
deal with it multiple times it's always
like you go from this seriously ship and
then this other girls now really mean oh
that's different yeah that's different
that's a certain I agree with that
someone's repeat though like it's never
just like one girl and then that was it
yeah
well he's got issues the same thing if
it was a woman and it got repeated do
you guys think
um that if a man
um is being abused and ends up
committing suicide over it do you think
that the woman is responsible and should
be held responsible in court 100 oh
never it's only if we reported it
exactly because now is now how do you
hold the woman accountable for that
that's just the issue on
if he dies before he reported it like
say like she slapped him or she was she
was hurting him and then she stabbed him
and went for an artery so it's obvious
that she killed him that way well yeah
sewer but if it was something like she
kept on abusing him and then he killed
himself but he never reported it I would
say the same thing for a woman it's sad
but if you reported it if you did report
it it's just gonna go down as you commit
suicide no but it's easier for society
to go and investigate the man than the
woman yeah that's what that's what I'm
saying 100 so let's take do you guys
remember when that only fans model
killed her boyfriend yes remember from
Florida the one in the elevator that he
was beating him yeah the Nigerian guy
yeah hey blessing can you Google
um the only fans model Florida Google
um elevator footage and see if you can
find it I want to show you guys and that
is what Auntie's talking about I don't
know anything about it
you will see it in the video so I'll
tell you basically
um there was a guy that was dating
um he was a very good looking Rich
um Nigerian guy I think he's Nigerian
yes um dating an only fans model she was
blonde she's very pretty
um and basically it came out that like
the couple was arguing a lot and in the
the building like there were times when
he had been sleeping in the hallway and
he He Turned Up Dead basically she
called the cops and he had been stabbed
I want to say
yeah and she actually didn't even get
arrested for it even though there were
multiple people that said that she had
been abusing him and she actually was
out partying like a day later she was
seen at a bar she's been out of jail for
months I think their pressing charges
now and I think she's in jail now but
she she was literally out and about for
months the premises isn't that no the
the police I wanted to say it so I'd
expect something if there's witnesses
that are willing to stand up and say
yeah this happened then yeah they should
do well yeah so let me put it on the
yeah put it on the screen he was
Nigerian he was Nigerian and she was
hitting him and he's that sense of
entitlements
but then this is where we black women
now cannot feel for you because we say
look at what you can't pick do you
understand like unfortunately I'm so
sorry because then you don't if they
don't value you know what right strong
women get abused weak women get abused
everybody because it shows strong men
get abused
because and but the way you sounded just
now
if I was a man and I heard the way you
saying that was a big tool Nigerian man
getting abused I won't say nothing
because the way that you said about him
being a bit like it was all right until
you find out he was Nigerian he had
money and he was six foot whatever tall
and then all of a sudden you changed
yeah because because
I said but if I said Effie was five foot
tall right a regular nine to five man
would you have that same impression no
you would have said he was weak but he's
Nigerian and they're not supposed to do
this extra weeks I also think that if if
she wasn't I'm sorry I think if she was
on Caucasian he wouldn't have taken it
exactly
because in America if now she reports
him he's screwed he is screwed
and I I understood from sources that he
also tried to leave her he wouldn't she
wouldn't let him leave her so probably
that's how it happened what do you mean
how can she stop him from leaving her
because because watch the video and I'll
tell you as many of you know I was was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible